welcome here at the kcata let me start
by giving a good shout out to my friend
robbie mackinnon and all those who are
the kcata who do wonderful work
[Applause]
now sometimes life comes full circle
about 30 years ago there was a kansas
city woman whose family moved a lot but
lived primarily on kansas city's east
side
she had three kids within five years of
age and got them around and herself
around on the bus riding to work each
and every day
the weights could be long on a cold day
the quarters it cost to ride at the time
could add up to taking food off of that
kid's table
but she kept riding to build
opportunities for herself and her family
that woman was my mother
that family was my family
but that story is just one story of
hard-working american families in kansas
city and the suburbs in the country and
in every state
infrastructure you see isn't about
objects it's about people
thank you
the kansas city and looking to find the
job that helps them reach the middle
class
the missourians who are looking for
access to the skills they need to be
competitive in the next generation and
the president's bill supported by my
congressman and forever my mayor
supported by a congresswoman who knows
the story of a hard-working mom who
always believed in her even when others
may not and supported by a bipartisan
consensus of americans across the
country will launch more success stories
build more good paying union jobs
[Applause]
and will help us build that better life
for all americans no matter where
they're from or where they start
i'm proud to stand here today with my
congresspersons we're proud to stand
here with the president and i'll note
here in kansas city i'm honored mostly
today to talk about a city that is
leading on zero fare and reduced
emissions public transportation
in early 2020 kansas city became the
first
major american city to implement a
permanent zero fair transit initiative
making all public transit fare free and
putting thousands of dollars two
thousand dollars per person back into
the pockets of hard-working men and
women in kansas city and during the
pandemic we never gave up on our public
transit system and importantly we never
gave up on the riders like my mother
those years before like the essential
workers who are going to work each day
and this is the type of transformative
work that we're talking about when we
say infrastructure is about equity it's
about jobs it's about connectivity it's
about opportunities
america's mayors america's congress
people and so many others are committed
to ensuring these dollars translate into
action lifting up communities where
government commitment will now and
finally match the hope and opportunity
in all people's hearts
kansas city the country's eyes are on us
and we will continue to showcase what it
means to be a city committed to
equitable service delivery and committed
to working for all folks in all
neighborhoods
now i know the president has an
appointment at some point with kansas
city barbecue so i'll keep us moving
along
i have to recognize just a few other
folks every sign today was printed
in-house in kansas city missouri with
good union labor of local 500 and i'd
like to thank everybody in public works
kcata fire department the police
department every worker in kansas city
let's give them a round of applause as
well
so we'll look forward to a continuing
partnership with the president we'll
look forward to a continuing partnership
as we implement these important dollars
and importantly as we were to get build
back better across the finish line we
look forward to having the president
back for more celebration but more than
anything i want to say god bless you all
this holiday season thank you all for
being part of this implementation and
let's have a wonderful time welcoming
the president
i want to make sure now that i turn it
over to somebody who's very special to
me somebody i met in school some years
ago and somebody who was a star then and
whose star has continued to rise an
outstanding representative for the
people of northeast kansas and i will
say for the people of america ladies and
gentlemen congresswoman therese davis
[Applause]
good afternoon i don't know if he
they i i i thought there would be a
little box
um well good afternoon everyone i'm
sharice davids i represent the kansas
3rd congressional district thank you all
so much for being here thank you all so
much for the work that you do because i
know that
this microphone
okay
uh i i know that all of you are here
because we get to talk about
two of my favorite things today
infrastructure
and
making sure that there are more
opportunities for the kansas city metro
area and i am so proud and lucky to be
joining mayor lucas congressman emmanuel
cleaver and the president of the united
states as we talk about the way that
this infrastructure bill is going to
have a positive impact on our country
on our children our grandchildren and
future generations i'm grateful that we
get to work together across state lines
to help this region thrive
we're
talking about
making sure that from bridges to
broadband we're continuing to create
create opportunities and connect our
cities
because that's what this is about
because
as mayor lucas said building
infrastructure addressing infrastructure
needs is so much more than the physical
stuff
it's of course our roads our bridges and
even broadband
it's infrastructure
is everyday systems
that help us get to where we need to go
that keep us healthy
get us to places of recreation
get us to our jobs
and i know that when we're talking about
this stuff whether it's
safety
on a highway like highway 69 or access
to high-speed internet
in all areas across kansas and missouri
both urban and rural
if we aren't investing in those systems
we're going to pay the price
and it's not just potholes and longer
bus stop weights but those are
i know
folks have felt those
so but it's not just that it's the
impact that we feel when decades of
under investment happen
on our economy
and right now we're in the middle of
addressing
a huge
economic crisis that was brought on by a
generational
pandemic
and i know it's been hard so i really
appreciate all of you who i know are
some of our frontline workers folks who
have literally kept our cities moving so
thank you all so much for the work that
you've been doing around that
uh it's time to stop
just kind of repairing our grandparents
infrastructure it's time to start
innovating it's time to start
championing
innovations that are going to make
a great economy for our future
generations for our grandchildren and
our great grandchildren
i of course have to bring up
fellow kansan president eisenhower
who knew a thing or two about bringing
an economy back by investing in
infrastructure
we get to do that here and now this is
the opportunity we have in front of us
we have a president who has taken that
head on
we have
congressmen
and women and people
like congressman cleaver we have mayors
like quinton lucas
and folks all across this country
who know that this is our opportunity
and we're taking it
we passed this bill in a bipartisan way
because this infrastructure
and some of these kitchen table issues
are
not partisan
these are the things that our country
needs so that we can move on
so we can make progress and
i'm excited about the billions of
dollars that are coming to our region
[Applause]
and i'm proud to work with the folks who
are here today so many of you and and of
course congressman cleaver and i who are
always meeting
and facetiming
about this stuff
thank you so much
i
do want to take a minute to say
congressman cleaver is not only my
friend he's my mentor
he is a leader in the u.s house that is
beyond compare
i feel fortunate that we get to have him
as our representative
uh in this district and
uh well you know what i mean
in this region
i'm like he's
and i just i cannot okay there's a
spider on the podium
i this happened at the last
infrastructure i'm not kidding
i'm so sorry
[Laughter]
cleaver has saved my life once again
i will turn it over to congressman
emmanuel
uh i i actually do know how to facetime
i know
my children wouldn't believe it but i do
it's been just about a a year ago back
in
february of last year
when senator
secretary of state ambassador john kerry
and i
rode from one end of iowa to the other
campaigning on a blue bus
for joe biden
in cedar rapids iowa
a person
asked me i want you to name
why would you endorse
fighting this
early and
it was clear then and it's clearer now
i explained that when i was mayor i was
waiting for the infrastructure ship to
come in
year after year after year after year
then i went to congress waiting for the
infrastructure ship to come in
year after year
after year and i knew
based on how he campaigned
that infrastructure was going to be
something that
a president joe biden
would push
and get through and i also realized that
one of the ways to get that shift in is
to swim out
and help pull it ashore
and that's what i did in congress
along with reece davis
helped pull it ashore
even though
i had to stand alone in missouri as the
only
person from missouri in the house to
vote for this
and i'm proud as one of the proudest
folks i've ever taken
and i
and so all i want you to understand the
people who are here and i want you to
tell everybody you know
ladies and gentlemen this is a big
working deal
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
please welcome the president of the
united states joe biden
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Applause]
good afternoon i'm s jackson a proud
member of atu 1287 here in kansas city
i'm so
i'm so honored to stand here on behalf
of more than 600 members of our local
and international president john costa
to introduce president joe biden
a man who was delivering on his promise
to get things done in washington
the president did exactly what he said
he would do
he reached across the aisle worked with
the other side and got a deal done and
this is going to be a big deal
especially here in kansas city
our infrastructure is crumbling and it's
not just our roads and bridges it's
about public transit
i've been a transit operator here for
six years
but the longer hours became too much
i have three children's age five six and
twelve
and needed to be home more so i recently
transferred to maintenance department
where i could work eight hours go home
for baseball games basketball games
and just be a dad
we have two electric buses here at the
kcata
and with the infrastructure bill i'm
sure we'll be getting many more
sooner our entire fleet will be electric
and i want to ensure that i have the
skill set to fix and maintain these
vehicles
thankfully thanks to the body team
the bill sets aside 500 million dollars
for training
the transit systems must use this money
for workforce development for people
like me
it's a really big deal
[Applause]
but that's what you'd expect from the
most pro-labor pro-trend president in
american history
[Applause]
since january he's brought hope
compassion and leadership to the white
house
he bought america back just in time
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
president of the united states and
former school bus driver joe biden
[Applause]
well i tell you what
i don't know where that phrase it's a
big deal came from
if anybody remembers that which you seem
to all remember
after
the president spoke and i spoke after
but i then president obama
he was back to my right
and i went back and i made sure i was
talking on his left ear because it was
all he was down the hallway
and i whispered what i said
how in god's name anybody heard it i
have no idea
and i shouldn't waste your time and tell
you this but we were going to go from
there
over the department of transportation no
excuse me department of education
i walked out the back and got in a
presidential limo
on the
on the driver's side
in the back seat the president
he was already in there he was laughing
like the devil he was almost hysterical
what's so damn funny and he told me
and i said you're just lucky my mother's
not alive i'd be one dead man
look before i begin
i'd like to say a word about a friend of
mine
we lost this weekend
man a few
hours west of russell
kansas came from our not far from here
in russell kansas
a lot of americans today remember bob
dole was a presidential candidate
but
for families he represented across the
border
he represented kansas for 36 years
and for those like me who had the honor
of calling him a friend
bob dole was an american giant
a man of extraordinary courage both
physical
and moral courage
a war hero
who sacrificed beyond measure
who nearly gave his life for our country
in world war ii
among the greatest of the great
generation
a leader of honesty decency and good
humor
the same qualities that made him such a
such a cherished friend to me and my
wife jill
and so many others through the years
we didn't agree on everything
but i always admired and respected him
and his willingness
to work with anyone any party
when it mattered most
and our nation owes bob dole a debt of
gratitude for the remarkable service
and a life
well-lived
being here this week reminds another
great american giant
or rather an american monarch
buck o'neill
kansas city monarchs
a great ball player
the first black coach in the majors
one of the game's greatest ambassadors
and finally
finally a hall of famer
[Applause]
now if the sun's shining a little
brighter on kansas city this week
is because bob and buck are up there
sharing a laugh with one another
also want to acknowledge mayor quinton
lucas mayor q
you've done an amazing job both in terms
of economic justice
as well as economic progress
and i want to thank
county executive frank
right he lived the life i'd hoped to
live
he started off as a laborer he helped
build the royal stadium as a player he's
one of the best players there and now
he's a county executive in jackson
county
resident in the business
to uh
uh
as well you know i mean this guy's done
it all
i thought maybe i could make him the
pros but look the hell
i actually was foolish enough to ask
floyd little whether he could get his he
was a friend of mine in syracuse if he
could get his agent to see if i can walk
on
you know 50
every year they allow 50 folks to walk
on
well guess what
he said he came back to me laughing he
said my agent said they're afraid to let
you walk on they have to just carry you
off
look
the infrastructure law i signed
thanksgiving
would not be possible this is not
hyperbole without the leaders here today
congress emanuel cleaver
was a great mayor
a significant leader in the house
before he's both those things he was a
pastor
and he saw
he saw a highway cut through the
neighborhood many of his congregants
call home
so he knows
that we need to build our infrastructure
the right way not just build it but
build it the right way
he also has a big reason
kansas city is adding electric buses to
his fifth fleet
zero fair zero emissions
congressman great idea
great
idea congresswoman sharice davis
there is no stronger advocate for
infrastructure investment in the united
states congress
that i've ever met anyway and as vice
chair of the house transportation
infrastructure committee
your your leadership was key in getting
this passed so i want to thank you there
you are thank you thank you thank you
[Applause]
i also want to thank somebody else rory
blunt he couldn't be here today but he
was an important part of the bipartisan
effort to get the infrastructure passed
and that's what this we're here about
we're here to talk about rebuilding
america investing in america building a
better america
in the coming weeks i'm going to be
traveling all over the country so will
vice president harris my cabinet and
folks throughout our administration
our building to better america tour is
going to give us a chance to meet people
where they work
where they work and hear what the
communities
that they live in
what they need hear firsthand
and showcase how our bipartisan
infrastructure law which has changed
their lives for the better came about
because we work together we can learn
more about this law and what it means
for your community go to build.gov
look
the better part of the 20th century
we led the world survive significant
margin and our willingness to invest in
ourselves
in ourselves
we invested in our infrastructure
we invested in research and development
in our roads highways bridges ports
airports the arteries of the nation
allow commerce to function smoothly and
move swiftly
and we invested in our people
we gave opportunity
we're among the first to provide access
to universal education and high school
education the beginning of 20th century
which put us in the forefront
of leading the rest of the world
we invested to win the space race and we
wanted
we led the world of research and
development led the creation of the
internet
but we know that china and the rest of
the world are catching up
in some respects actually moving beyond
us
we're also going to reinvest in our
country and our people to reclaim our
leadership to create millions of jobs
by building a better america
with the best infrastructure in the
world
built overwhelmingly with prevailing
wage union
union
union
[Music]
there's a lot of
[Music]
there's a lot of good and decent people
in the finance industry but they didn't
build the middle class
unions built the middle class now not a
joke not a political statement it's a
reality
it's a reality
and look
this infrastructure bill which without
the union's support behind me to get
this done
would have never gotten done it starts
with the most significant investment
in roads and bridges in america in 70
years
fixing many of those 3 000 500 bridges
nearly 10 000 miles of roads in kansas
and missouri
in poor condition
like the central avenue bridge which was
closed earlier this year for fear of
failure
a similar bridge not far from here going
to kentucky it was fear of failure it
collapsed
killing a whole heck of a lot of people
but this created a whole lot of
headaches
wasted time for 8 500 people to use to
drive it every single day
the decaying roads
cost missouri and kansas drivers more
than 500
per person per year
the drivers
and the additional gas and repairs
and longer commute times
and more than 500 hidden tax on kansas
and missouri families
and speaking of the cost of living
two weeks ago i announced the largest
ever release
of the u.s strategic petroleum reserve
to increase the supply of oil to help
bring down prices
i met with our friends around the world
other countries joined us
and those savings are starting to reach
drivers now today the average price
you're paying here in kansas city is
below two dollars a gallon two or three
dollars a year it's down to 290 a gallon
20
down from cents for from a month ago
nationally prices are down seven cents a
gallon continuing to fall
we're making progress
we're going to keep at it to ensure the
american people are paying their fair
share for gas
not being gouged for gas
look
look
as manuel
man said we're we're in a situation
where we've known
that our infrastructure had problems for
a long long time
i don't think i could take one more
phrase that's going to be infrastructure
weak
but guess what
it's going to be infrastructure decade
now man
no more talking
action
we'll also include the most significant
investment in passenger rail in 50 years
66 billion dollars
for passengers and freight rail
you know
i was talking with members about
improving cross-state interstate
passenger rail
something i know a little about
i've been doing it for a long time
you know the fact is that uh you're
looking at mr amtrak here
i've traveled over the chicago travel
over a million 250 000 miles on amtrak
everybody thought that uh anyway because
i went home every single night after my
wife and daughter were killed because i
couldn't afford a home in delaware and
in washington so i commuted every day
i remember
one day
the as vice president
the uh the government keeps fastidious
records of how many miles you travel on
government planes
and so there's a big headline
biden travels i forget was a million
miles on air force two and so on and so
forth
and i'm getting on the train to go home
which the
secret service are great they're with me
here today all 800 of you
but all kid aside they're wonderful
and i was getting on the train because
they didn't like me getting on the train
uh congressman because there's a more
dangerous circumstance you can stop
people fix on tracks etc
and but i would go going home and see my
mom who was sick
and one of the conductors to know for
years walked up and aggression joey baby
grabbed my cheek
and not a joke
and uh and i thought that he was gonna
get shot
uh
true story and i said i said no no it's
okay we've known each other joey
big deal
a million miles or wherever it was a
million miles on air force two
come on joey you know how many miles you
travel on amtrak
i said no ange i don't know how many
miles he said we
we calculated it
at the retirement dinner
he said
36 years
119 days a year
back and forth
then as vice president we figure you've
done x number trips
it adds up to 1 million 200 000 miles on
amtrak
and i said
if my dad were here he'd call him
misspent adulthood
but all kidding aside
you know back in the early 70s probably
74 i think it was
or is a guy named charlie wheeler talked
about this your mayor
careful
there's no reason why
it should be two hours faster to drive
from kansas city to st muslin take a
train
no reason
all the data shows that if you get from
point a to point b
at a faster rate by rail than by
automobile you take the rail
and guess what that does
first of all it's safer but secondly
it's going to save over time millions of
barrels of oil
millions of barrels of oil
because it's electric
look folks
we're the largest
investment in public transit ever in
this legislation advantage replacing
buses that are past their useful life
switching from diesel to electric
getting more people
where they're trying to go more safely
faster cleaner
like what you're doing here
with your
zero fare zero emission buses
electric buses
you add into the fleet it's a
win-win-win
they're manufactured here in america
creating good union jobs
they're good for the environment
and they're making them free for all
riders mayor you're helping regular
riders save about 2 000 bucks a year
that's a big deal for someone making 50
60 grand a year
an infrastructure
law means more projects like the
extension of the kansas city streetcar
so you can connect union station with km
excuse me umkc
and everything in between i mean
students can easily get to internships
and jobs in downtown core it means
families can get to restaurant stores
the plaza
to read the riverfront to catch the
kansas city current game at the new
stadium the first stadium by the way i
might specifically point out
specifically built for women's soccer
i was able to see and win the olympic
anyway it's a long story but
it means more jobs
opportunity economic development
the law invests 42 billion dollars
to modernize our ports and airports in
america
like the new terminal you're building
the kansas city international
or improvements to the island port and
the missouri river helping get
agricultural products from the midwest
to the rest of the nation
and this bill has 16 billion dollars in
it
to improve ports like yours
these investments make it easier
easy for companies to get their goods to
market reducing supply chain bottlenecks
lowering costs for families
here in kansas city the possibilities
are unlimited
you've got the fastest growing port in
the midwest
you're the in the heart of the heartland
for freight rail
for transforming your airport
you're building a national hub
create a cycle of jobs and growth
that'll be be felt for decades
making the right investments and you
have the money to do it now of course
that's not all the law achieves
under the leadership of
mayors like uh you know our mayor here
kc water has going to replace all known
service lines is kansas city but there's
more work to be done in the region
the law starts by replacing all 100
percent
of the nation's lead pipes and service
lines so every child in missouri and
kansas and across america can turn on
that faucet
in the 4 000 schools you can't do it 44
000 i should say
and drink clean decent water
we're going to need
you're going to need tens of thousands
of plumbers and pipefitters making a
union wage to and do this
you get paid a prevailing wage
with benefits
the ability to build a middle class life
i grew up like a lot of you did i grew
up in a nice three-bedroom
level home and a development of about 70
other homes like it
with four kids and a grandpa living with
us
but i remember every time something
would happen my dad i remember when he
lost his health insurance's company you
could tell the walls were thin how upset
he was that night just rolling in bed
matter
he said dad doesn't have we don't have
health insurance for a while honey
my dad you say everybody deserves just a
little bit of breathing room
a little bit of breathing room
this law is going to make high-speed
internet affordable available everywhere
in america
creating jobs deploying those broadband
lines
across the high-speed internet on access
to high-speed internet unlocks
opportunity everywhere it allows farmers
in kansas to use precision agriculture
to improve their yields
or a doctor in st louis to have a remote
checkup with a homebound cancer patient
today roughly one of every four
missourins and one out of every three
six in kansas
don't have high-speed internet in their
home
in some places there's no broadband
infrastructure at all
this law will make high-speed internet
affordable and available everywhere in
missouri and kansas urban suburban and
rural
in the 21st century in america no parent
should have to do what many had to do
last semester
and that is sit in the parking lot of a
fast food restaurant
so their children could use the internet
to get their homework done
this is the united states of mayor for
god's sake
this law also builds out of resilience
against extreme weather events
fueled by climate change
nasty last year
extreme weather events cost this country
99
billion dollars
and i toured most of it
i was out in california you know more
forest burned to the ground
burned to the ground
than the entire square mileage of the
state of new jersey from
cape the cape all the way up to new york
city and long island
that's how much we lost them and it goes
on
missouri and kansas is no stranger to
these effects
in fact missouri and kansas were both in
the top 10 states in the u.s last year
for power outages
then texas then texas saw the massive
blackouts last winter
because you're on the southwest power
grid you lost power too
this summer you saw heavy storms close
roads in waverly kansas caused flooding
in saint joseph to colombia to jefferson
city
and when you think about the impact
of more intense weather more severe
storms none of us are ever going to
forget the devastation in joplin
in 2014 i went there to help reopen the
rebuilt joplin high school
of joplin
we never break
we never stop
we americans always rebuild
and we will rebuild this country
and this law
builds back our bridges our water
systems our power lines electric grids
better stronger
more resistant to the negative effects
of climate change because by the way
it used to be as the elected officials
here can tell you
if you had storm damage and you
qualified for federal aid you got them
just enough amount of damage money money
to get you back to exactly what it
looked like before
but you can't do that
because now that highway gets flooded
out it's never going to go back to less
rain
because of global warming pray god it
won't get worse so you got to build that
highway a couple feet higher it costs
more money you got to build back better
there's so much more in this law
most of all the law does something truly
historic
the law helps rebuild what i when i
announced for office i said i was
running for three reasons
one to restore the soul of this country
a sense of decency and honor
two
to rebuild the backbone of this country
working class and hard-working
middle-class people that's the backbone
of this country and thirdly to unite the
country which is turning out to be one
of the most difficult things but we're
going to get it done
look
the fact of the matter is
that we've been able to do an awful lot
we built america
and we've left behind
so much for so long
we're going to help rebuild the economy
this time from the bottom up in the
middle out
you know a blue cop this bill is a
blue-collar blueprint for working
americans
95 of the jobs created in the
infrastructure bill
don't require a college education
the only way this works is blue collar
americans do the building
and the only way it ever worked
we're going to do it again
mark my words we're going to do this
again
and the same goes my plan to build back
better for our people
this bill is going to deliver for
example universal pre-k for every three
and four-year-old in america
one study
great university have done a lot of
studies on this in the last decade
one study shows that low-income children
from poor homes
participating in preschool
are 47 more likely to go on to earn an
associate's degree or higher after high
school
they start off at a great disadvantage
because their mom or their dad their
single parent doesn't have the education
doesn't have the training
but at three years old the brain is
rapidly developing so quickly it matters
we have to build that foundation
for the future for success
my wife chill is the first is a
full-time teacher
and you know she says any nation that
out educates us
is going to out compete us
it's simply a fact
and guess what
hold it here
every nation
of the 38 most advanced nations we rank
34 in the world
34 in the world
in early education for children the
united states of america
my buildback better plan which is passed
in the house of representatives thanks
to my two colleagues here today
representatives will also ensure that
parents can afford child care
child care gets workers
raised and child care workers get a
raise they deserve folks look
in missouri and kansas the average
annual cost to send a toddler to child
care is six thousand five hundred
dollars a year
if you live in chicago it's more like
twenty two thousand dollars a year for a
child okay
it means that the average family
with two young children spending roughly
20
of their
after-tax income
on child care
twenty dollars however 100 they have
our build back better bill is going to
make a giant difference in life because
your child care cost will be capped at
seven percent of your income
period
that's seven percent of your income
it's going to make a huge difference and
millions of workers have had to drop out
of the workforce not because they didn't
want to work but because they couldn't
find affordable care
look at all the women who are totally
qualified who had to drop out of the out
of the workforce because they can't
afford the child care and still work
look folks
you know uh
it's not the same but
i started about about community one of
the reasons i started commuting was when
i got elected
my family was killed my wife and
daughter were killed i couldn't afford
to leave delaware because i had a
sister's my best friend my brother
my mother my father helped me raise my
kids i was making good money i was
making forty two thousand dollars a year
as a senator i could no more afford
full-time child care than fly
we're going to make college more
affordable
right now the cost of a two-year degree
in missouri
is over four thousand dollars a year
in kansas it's over three thousand
dollars a year
there are about 140 000 students in
these two states that rely on what we
call pell grants and make less than 50
grand a year pell grants help cover the
cost
this plan i have
also is going to increase pell grants by
550 a year
it makes it easier to stay in school it
makes a big difference
we're also
we're also going to lower prescription
drug prices
this week i spoke to a young woman who
told me the cost of insulin for her
diabetes
which is stage so type 1 diabetes men
having to choose between rent
groceries
and medication she said relentlessly
without relief every day
so she couldn't do it
so she began to ration her supply of
insulin she ended up in a coma and
almost died think about that the
difference between nearly dying and
thriving
is the cost of one drug that cost ten
dollars to make years ago nothing's
changing it
that could cost consumers now one
thousand dollars a month
well so if you're one of those americans
you're paying too much for insulin my
buildback better plan is going to change
that too because you're going to
guarantee you pay no more than 35
a month
it'd be different
if they invested another 1500 bucks in
research they did nothing
to change it
they'll make sure parents of the 200 000
children in america with type 1 diabetes
have the ability to parent to have the
ability to say to a child honey it's
going to be okay can you imagine
the dignity
you'll be deprived as a parent knowing
your child has type 1 diabetes and you
can't afford
their insulin
you can't afford it
because you don't have insurance
and your state doesn't have medicare
look
it's all about what working middle class
people have to pay to get by to get
ahead to get as my dad said that little
bit of breathing room
my whole plan is designed to bring down
the cost you face for example
lower cost for child care making sure
you don't pay more than seven percent of
your income means the family making
fifty thousand bucks a year will save
three thousand dollars a year on child
costs
lowering the cost of prescription drug
making sure you pay no more than 35
bucks a month for instance not a hundred
not a thousand a month
saving six hundred dollars per person
per year for health care premiums the
list goes on elder care housing
meeting the moment of climate change
that's what this plan does
all in
a study found that my plan would mean
the equivalent of seven thousand four
hundred dollars in tax cuts and savings
for the typical family of four with two
kids
and guess what
let's talk about inflation it's real
there's inflation
the nobel 17 nobel winners of the
economics have written a letter
just about three weeks ago to me
affirming that this bill would ease
long-term inflationary pressures
in the economy
two of the leading rating agencies in
the world the wall street journal
confirmed my plans do not add to
inflationary pressures
not liberal thanks wall street
moody's and anyway
look
i i have also proposed but what i
proposed is in a way to lower some of
the difficult costs families that they
pay every month
by asking corporations in the wealthiest
americans to pay their fair share for
change
look
right now
everybody talks about the price tag for
this legislation
a trillion 750 billion dollar it will
not cost the taxpayers a penny
if you're making less than 400 grand a
year
you're not going to have your taxes go
up one
single penny
not a cent
and guess what else
it also means
that there is no
no increase
no increase in your taxes and people are
going to just pay a fair share for
example there are 50 corporations in
america the last three years
of the fortune 500 that made 40 billion
dollars that didn't pay one
single solitary penny
not one single penny in taxes
come on folks
you have it used to be during the last
bush administration
top rate for the top one percent
paid 37.5 percent
it could lowered to 36 percent
it's not any impact it just means
whether or not they're going to have an
extra swim and pulls the extra home
put all kids aside
if you just take it from down to from 36
back up to 37.5
it pays for every bit of preschool
and a pays for every bit of what we're
talking about in terms of insulin
now what's better for american
corporations what's better for the
wealthy
for a healthier nation
everybody being better educated
or having that extra amount of money
that they already have a great deal of
i'm a capitalist
i always have i have a good friend of
bernie's but we disagree i'm not a
socialist i'm a capitalist
you should be able to make a million or
100 million bucks if you can
but pay your fare share
folks look
there's so much we can do
so many things that
are within our power
if you went to the average american
family making
60 to
70 grand or you went to a family where
dad was a teacher and mom was a police
officer making 120.
they're paying at a higher tax rate than
someone making a trillion dollars i mean
a billion dollars
for real
how can that be fair
look one of the reasons i feel so firmly
in the proposals is because
i know what this country can be
we've always been a nation of
possibilities
we didn't become this nation by thinking
small we've always thought big
throughout our history
we've emerged from crisis by investing
in ourselves and our people
during the civil war
before it was over
lincoln started to build the
transcontinental railroad
it was built at the end of and
during the civil war
during the cold war
eisenhower built the interstate highway
system
transforming the way americans lived
and now we're at work beginning
in building the economy of the 21st
century
to build a better america
i truly believe and i promise you this
i believe that 50 years from now
when historians look back on this moment
they're going to say this was the moment
that america won the competition
for the 21st century
think about it most of you who are
over 40 remember us always having the
number one infrastructure in the world
the most best education etc
we rank now number
eight in the world in terms of
investment research and development
14th in infrastructure the united states
of america
and if you're a businessman out there
or you work or you're a labor a union
person working for business
where's the business going to go
where they can get the products to
market fastest
safest where they have access to get in
and out but they have access to move
that's why we're losing
that's why we're losing
we're not going to lose any more
i promise you the time of losing is over
it's over over over over
god bless you all
and may god protect our truth
thank you for your patience i appreciate
it thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me